Michael do you ever worry that our
friendship will not survive Resident
Evil and it wasn't I didn't know we
still were friends
stuck with me now last episode was a
tough one
there's something to be said about co-op
and the fact that you can both help each
other but also bring stress and
grievances upon each other I'm past it
let's start a new lettuce I love you I
forgot what happened last time I was the
boss fight oh yeah so we're coming up on
ah
I'm giving me like 20 more minutes I
think before we catch up to where we
were before that mishap when we lost
everything my heart all right well let's
do it I also think we've learned a lot
since that time because there was a
fight we didn't know how to do it but
now we know how to do it so I think
everything will be easier now what's all
this nonsense about evolution ah shame I
miss your voice check for ammo around
what about a philosophy oh yeah there
was a lot today
no matter what she says she's just a
terrorist end of story
can't risk people who's getting out of
it I sound like a politician sorry [ __ ]
doesn't matter who she is she's she's a
terrorist end of story
I'm not talking about this anymore move
on doesn't matter who she is she's an
Eagles fan I [ __ ] hate her mm-hmm it
was the biggest most people in the
audience ever period all right wait what
oh that was a Spicer joke oh gosh
oh this is is this the right thing
there's two options here oh there is
you take shotgun you know what I'm full
I'll reload your handgun okay I'm good
one round in your chamber right now I
didn't read any of them I'll take a
machine gun oh wait the feel like this
is important
oh you're not gonna be able to fit the
shotgun shells I'll take them both for
now then give you when you need it well
I didn't think that very safe right here
Kroy Nene Lee unlocked diamond groin
chest what's that
is that a neck oh yeah no it's his neck
back here it looks like it I see a groin
what's that
those little balls speaking of yep get
out of there I'm your partner with
visual partners like him like holes
those are mine - Ava and Chris get it on
I've never felt violated about balls
before but it seems like that's really
important feel like the world should
speak up about this more shovel I saw
you mashing that circle button what
that's ridiculous
it's Friday night we're recording this
so I have it is Friday night after a
long week so I have coffee and beer and
we're just so you guys know cuz oh [ __ ]
oh yeah if you're watching this episode
this episode of lose a shotgun shell on
the boxes yeah we we let the we have
people who like our I call them
GameSpot's back-end angels who make sure
all the videos and everything go up and
they always work really late and they
reference to the sites back they work
really hard
oh not like but angels anyway angels 3s
angels it sounds like a movie I would
see anyway they're gonna go home cuz
it's Friday night and they shouldn't
have to stay so this video will go up on
Monday up wrap they're all shooting at
me so you've seen Wow no never mind
never mind
you have no head you have no head you
have no head check pretty good eh hmm
house shoes new suit hmm
I mean I didn't oh this is the this is a
bad one up I'm gonna shoot as are things
he's dangled yeah
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
got it got it die do your final move
stab em nice
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
[Music]
yea-ah
show your head
[Music]
that's enough what's that a bug okay
wait is there two of them
nice oh wait this guy's alive notice
where this guy's got a gun right I shot
him in the butt oh I think pull that
lever if you can okay oh my god I never
did you scream like I do was it that
funny yeah I think any time guys scream
like hi it's funny come on
thanks thanks oh I will scream really
falsetto voice if I see a snake like a
real one
yeah oh wow I didn't know that was I
don't know what weapon is this the PSG I
might take this under teat a bit I
cannot take this grenade but the red
herb is more important can you combine
that or no I only have a rudder
yeah there's psg right here kind of
wanna get that and sell it later this
you don't have room for it I know as I'm
saying I'm trying to figure out how I
can have him actually here give me that
okay I'll take that and don't wanna
overload myself with weapons
I'm not even gonna use that but no I can
give you okay this might what are you
doing seem like it's not worth it but it
is no no no no no okay I'm just getting
rid of these uh-huh seven more uh-huh
never got reload now I got a free slot
oh wow I have an extra gun I'm taking
this red herb all right sweet I have a
gun
cool I have a gun in my not to sell it
I'm gonna sell this sniper it's I got
two red herb so keep on the looks like a
great power in here I don't know
yep it I just I see levers I pull them
I'm a simple girl I see levers I pull
into you know I mean um I mean like my
own lever
yes it's like cool like I don't mind
okay so he's got the oil [ __ ] that guy
I gotta pull this with leave hair okay
I'm in it he just threw it so I stopped
him with this button oh there's a guy at
the other control console can you pull
out your rifle and kill that guy over
there
oh you're seeing right now are you thank
you I'm trying there's a fat guy and I'm
gonna go alright he's sitting ducks
idiot oh he's dead quick get the
platform over here so we can get the
loot before it's gone okay is this where
we send one person we have to yeah okay
I first actually I'll go
it's more exciting life I wait what's
that though oh that's a bangle hurry why
did it spawn over there I don't know
here but hurry into that switch when you
get over there
but bangle right pull that switch when
you get a chance
Rep somebody's shooting at me oh sure
he's right next to you
I know [ __ ] you [ __ ] left me me I
just covered you he almost hit yourself
he's got a bad shooting him public
switch again when you get the chance if
he do okay I'm working on it turn the
gameplay down a little bits like here
are poison mark hey I pulled it
there's a thing on this thing he's dead
no he's alive laughs he got me what's
what the [ __ ] just hit me was weird
maybe was one of those fine young
gentlemen
Oh he'd shot there's a green herb but
more importantly that guy has a nuke
thing an RPG yeah
crabs are different I'll kill him he is
not dead so weird Baldo moves he's not
dead yet
the [ __ ] here we go thank you oh but
Oh was nice nice news
stomp
hoo-whee he has stuff in his ooh oh I
got a that's never happened before I
took a lot of ant that guy exploded the
infinites on him he would his stomach
his stomach that's weird um can you do
me I'm almost dead try to figure how to
get this courier I know that's important
um okay wait let's look let's talk about
this uh I am willing to throw this gun
away I don't know if you can
[Music]
hey we're thinking over here you
[ __ ]
get stomped Oh hit see it's happening um
shouldn't have picked up this psg I
don't need it
Oh Oh cuz someone else is throwing that
[ __ ] oh that's fun
I'm just saying like that herb is more
important than my gun um no I gave you
uh can you drop it though I'll drop my
sniper cubed hey keep moving up that
waved me Oh God you're moving I'll heal
you when we get up there I got it I got
it we stop now we'll both your hip I got
it I got it oh [ __ ] Oh battle to the
finish Magan nice ah both reloading for
our very lives
thank you mm-hmm snake do you hear that
[ __ ] you not you what how can i dinner
okay
get out of the way [ __ ] okay this is
just I'm not this enough just attack him
from also an idiot
um this dude has an RPG quiche into the
window yeah sure
appears to be able to not see fit blast
ahhh oh my god
there's rifle ammo I just walked over
that was like you can see the RPGs like
flow by air another red and green herbs
very stressful
I should have reloaded before it got
that not fun no consequences
let's go sage reload now
um everybody's on a bus to the airport I
don't think the store they killed a
bunch of dudes behind you yeah
[Music]
okay I'm ready be your time happy Friday
hmm um unfortunately obviously it's
Monday for people watching this so I
could soldier it's just notoriously not
nearly as cool of a day Mike you still
drink that TG I am the thing about
drinking is is that you can do it any
day of the week at any time while to
figure it out for once I did it I change
it's a bit it's actually a bit unnerving
once you realize you can do it in fact
I'm not sure why other people don't do
it and that's what makes me feel weird
about it I can't put that in gonna I can
do here no no I want to hand in let me
give you shotgun shells okay that's fine
oh my god it's a bunch of boxes I'm
gonna get these boxes I got some boxes
over here oh I can't go on that I don't
want either those I can take I can't
take them except could you I'm [ __ ]
filled with rifle ammo I have so many
rifles I don't know what to do with the
mom oh this is one we have to shoot
those dudes what dudes those guys that
are like stopping us from rotating
downward oh yeah this is a dumb scene
well that's negative it's fine in fact I
think last time we did this um I wish we
did have them like we have it does them
audio but like we cheese did maybe we
could do that as a bonus episode we put
it out but we put it too like we can
have the audience vote on why don't we
we should play it why don't we verbally
say all of the sound effects do you see
that oh and just add level we're saying
yeah
[ __ ] all right we go here's the first
dude your rifle might come in handy
what do you mean remember they go up to
the levers here and then stop us from
rotating yes I do remember that I'm on
it
I'm on lever man cover me
never man man adders Musa no Oh for
[ __ ] sake I gotta be oh I got an
emblem on accident too what do you mean
I shot him and that shot an emblem
behind mine accident or you might have
Scheinman up oh I shot that guy
sometimes I get upset because I feel
pretty confident that I shot someone but
then the game says that I didn't I'm not
very good at this
uh-uh pores all right I got it Oh
all right I got it
show me it's down below us I got him
no I got him I shot him a little bit me
shoot two different but he shot two
different people
we might gotten both the same time it
works out oops
dang he's a weird one
we got past them we do it so good for us
Oh shots are being fired I see them do
you see them yeah I'm just gonna go
straight to the stairs you know what do
you have a grenade no I'm just gonna go
straight upstairs that's cool
making my way upstairs faces good oh my
god I'm coming
alright I got overzealous I'll say what
make him go away
Vanessa Carlton doesn't worry yeah the
way Galloway got away got all the way a
fly well you're almost dead I have help
for you okay um well let me kill this
guy and then we're gonna save you sorry
I did it good job me victim OOP wait
wait don't move when I use this
this guy's gonna explode making my way
to face huh okay fasten the pump huh
stop it I don't like it you can give me
um you can give me the rifle mo
but but but Reggie Oh snakes just sounds
like snakes I guess I don't know what
that is cuz I oh alright
oh this part I'm calling it I do not
like this part we figured it out after
other um I think I should go toppings
you have a rifle you can cover me with
we want to fly did it though last time
and it was really cool
but it'll look cooler to everybody else
cuz you get to get to watch you cover me
with rifle I think it's cooler when I'm
in the follow me shared weapons in the
thick of it okay I can't help you as
much as you haven't Renata I don't have
like long-range weapons to help you out
got it unless you could find me a rifle
mm-hmm that's broken there's a box over
here hold on there's a box alright let's
try with you first let's do it if I die
you can we'll go back and forth okay
right or you know but don't worry about
it Ivan up you slide I have an idea
do you think you'll be using your rifle
you could just give it to me temporarily
okay oh no no no you can't give weapons
which is dumb I think that's an
oversight in this game I didn't know
that oh yeah you're right way way hon
can you why is that just why is that
even an option I don't know
alright you can go try I won't be able
help you out that much I I got it you
got I'm feeling it I have this um rocket
grenade launcher and I feel pretty good
about it
send me up scotty Sheva alright have fun
it's a lot of those liquors I know this
took us a couple tries I should have
given you my green herb actually that's
okay I got full health right
I am not sticking around here just
hanging out until they decide sometimes
they decided to tag me sometimes they
don't
oh my god I'm using all of them on these
[ __ ] yes did you take a lot more
than they share today hmm
diet that took so many yeah holy cow
no I can try for actually while they're
crawling off this wall right here I can
shroom
yeah that'd be great I don't know how
much good it's gonna do but you can
shoot any of them that's a huge bonus
for meri
Oh
like do they come so many we didn't do
last time I shoot him twice you fell off
oh that's great cuz it's like a time
issue isn't it yeah uh wait [ __ ] my bag
one minute up okay I can deal with one
it's like oh my god
I think you also got him cuz I can see
your little laser thing mm-hmm
[ __ ] lame there's a sweet brown I
don't move yet there's one on the other
side there's acid rounds here I'll be
really nice to have should I get rid of
this gun yeah anybody yes
cuz I really want them also taking most
of the shin gunner I really want these
acid rounds get up
good ladies ones stuff these are pretty
nice all right so are sorry any of those
liquors here yeah but I I'll get them
this time try to move fast they're
coming out like indefinite okay I'm
coming icon icon uh yeah if you keep
going so just can you just verbally warn
me when they're on my butt I can only
see the ones on the wall right now you
should be able to have a good view of
when they're behind you though hmmmm so
far I haven't let any of them get up
thank you
one more
just knocking them off mm-hmm all right
I'm damn I'm gonna lick it I'm gonna
nope that's all of them I think yeah
sweetheart that was much easier okay
knock it off I think that's the way
yours hey posture uh just no haul come
to jump down you jump down out of there
knock out and open the door for me so we
can both didn't come out to here we have
more room below okay move to coming I
don't think you need the latter all
right can I come out here we'll just way
from out here it's unlocked
well yeah just come on it's unlocked I
know I'm just saying I'm not come out
that's unlocked I donate have a flashing
all right let's come out here okay here
they come
you're knocking at I sorry I don't know
I didn't hurt me but I reacted
oh sure you got it
would you shut the door I haven't jumped
at me Beckham rounds oh another flash
grenade I think they're all dead
we can get these boxes early sweet first
time is job thanks I'm really low on
ammo there's machine gun ammo in here
and these lockers what's up with these
I'm gonna pull this beaver and then I
think you should go up here because it
was a box up there and there might be
ammo for you as well all right mystery
Oh
oh there's a first-aid spray take it
okay
magnum handgun Magnum take it actually
and then there is a box up here it is
survey says machine gun ammo damn it
there's also a green herb hidden in the
corner but I'm like officially out of
room here I've got to think only wait
wait take the green herb first and come
Ben it so that you have double green and
then get the other thing yes Mar damn
mm-hmm severs murder there's like a
buzzing in this room do you hear it
mm-hmm
waiting the gamer oh look what I found
sapphire ruby sapphire blue dum-dum it's
so light I hate it backlight the blue
thing over see oh look what I found
topaz
[ __ ] pervert forever no doesn't kind of
sound like pervert Axela keone right
there say evil people are such generic
evil people
yeah just kidding I'll tell you here she
has fought evil people my bird days
stop playing around we want some answers
you haven't shaved crocodile leather
matter are alive
[Music]
we last met at the Spencer estate wasn't
DLC where Chris like I haven't be late
for the CI one big family were you
I would expect you to be happier to see
us
so slow to catch on
still home he shoots her anyway Jill
it's me Chris what are you sure that's
her the one and only she jumped forward
so far
pretty cool to see zero suit Jill and
accent action like she's pretty like
cool fast and got like Bigfoot
[Music]
now
appreciate we just survived for like
seven minutes or so I think the odds of
oh for the first session right you know
I'm supposed to can I like talk to her
or that's after seven minutes ago like
expanded lately seven minutes and so
you're saying I can't win or do anything
we just have to live yeah I could be
wrong rabbit he's shooting at me I mean
we can like you thinking perks I'm gonna
hide behind the store what he found me
be afraid to fight him I don't think I
don't know like
who's shooting at you
but I can't shoot at Jill right you
can't I don't think we can kill her
right now I could be wrong I don't fight
her hi my name is killer
well she's shooting at me got her hey
you can restrain her right now you're
come oh no mister uh what are you doing
I don't know
gonna come coming do anything right to
your left coming
ah but right great yeah okay I can I can
chuck her on the ground
yeah hurt like chess jewel wasn't
exposed yet Oh Dodge I don't know gonna
hammer Walter here I shot him I shot him
I shot him nice oh we need me in the
face Oh he punched me in the face I'm
hurt oh you know what I have it yeah
flash grenades there herbs right next to
the stairs and it's like curved I I also
have hers
I got injured pretty badly
how's he able to do that
hinges upon this fight whoops
crying a member would like this time to
change tactics
let's open up every pot we can we should
hide hide mm-hmm I'm just holding Jill
right now until um it's he you wait for
me father forgot to dodge yeah I see him
I see him I really want that pot though
yes I can
I'm like literally doing it right now Oh
there's red uh plant in here it's all
sorts of goo in here
[ __ ] you Jill oh no hold on I might walk
her way actually I might be able to get
to you nice about to kill me I'm like I
can see you damn it how she was knocked
down so
shovel uh um Tiana I wish I could have
sold that gun that makes me sad
cuz like few other things too so in this
particular fight we like don't need any
of this stuff
right well yeah you know help cuz like
you don't shoot her
yeah I get to shoot her chest eventually
Dan that give me a lot of money actually
thinking alright I'll take all those
things back but that gives me three
slots to like I don't know to get like
an herb or something you might need then
I'll save your life hurry got all
available upgrades for this come on come
on come on come on
so I'm gonna do that next time let's
just get through this bus fight all
right
[Music]
you mean I did a good job
[ __ ] you
jail all right I'm gonna go find shot
him in the butt I'm gonna you want to
come thrower with me okay
that's [ __ ] okay me Oh duh
[Music]
I'm coming
I got you keep restraining her until
Westar comes up I'll shoot Westar
hey girl don't you remember all those
good times we had oh I got shot I'm
dying I can't shoot her right or can i I
don't think so oh no I keep it to a
minimum so I definitely am in danger
physically I don't have any help us oh I
do
oh god I can't jump down right there
okay Oh Chuck you like a frisbee [ __ ]
all right go
I'll go toward the stairs I need to heal
yeah
there's a curb near the stairs oh right
I see your selfish [ __ ] thing happens
all right dodge dodge now we were
nowhere there come back - chase I'm not
going for that pot I don't know the
herbs are going what the [ __ ]
I took some magic can you use it right
now yes but I don't want to do it near
him cuz he's bad
[Music]
Rob it's me no shot him a few times
[ __ ] you Wesker cat you're such a dumb
character
scary game there absolutely is though
like that's like super misleading Here I
am opening all these pots take an mo
from pong and a boss do you want to meet
up or I like wet uh I'm just getting a
but yeah sure okay I'm not really doing
anything
oh there's machine gun ammo in here days
are better beer
dang I need that red herb where are you
um right here hey what oh [ __ ] look at
our [ __ ] system um we love shotgun to
begin with
we can jump down here so like oh there's
Jill [ __ ] you
I'm bi restrainer yeah I jump down an
exit sorry I'm coming back up though
um let's go back up I got her
oh you just like Roker nut Crotched her
possibly to death a groin grabbing ly
good time
well that sucks
I have to Greene's funds well if any of
us needs it will use one green and then
I'll pick up the red and get another one
I got this Jill if you want to do that
other that crotch thing again to her
with pleasure
why not get ready to dodge yeah I [ __ ]
was not paying attention
[Music]
what Branca
[Music]
ah [ __ ] that did a lot of damage to me
stop it
I got her if you want to keep her busy
um you can use a grater if you want me
hate that guy
[Music]
[ __ ]
keep that guy oh no she's shooting me
here I got her if you want yeah all
right I'm coming you up ah I can she's a
quick I feel like I should have done
that with you all right
I just more worried about I shot him in
the butt Chuck is it in seven minutes
yet
huh she's knocked out for a bit maybe
she spoke something well you know wait
until you like a tax but don't waste
anyone till the attacks or until he like
goes to shoot pal I was going yeah like
that
still gosh the hood hmm [ __ ] what yeah
counter-attack that [ __ ] I gotta heal up
much behind you oh [ __ ] it's Bella clean
out yeah
oh [ __ ] I shot I shot her I'd like to
say that it was an accident
can you heal me well I was gonna get the
red and fully heal you did something
right
Oh where's that red those about to start
shooting where's that red yeah that way
mm this way okay let's just do it
together here then to the left I believe
nope
we're tech to work forgot how we got
over there I forget so - so just come
with me if I need to I'll put all just
I'll heal you but let's do our best sit
all right don't jump down where's that
door over there for long wait times
oh no it's underneath us I think yeah
shut down before [ __ ] you Jill Mary oh
now it's easy I expected more of a
challenge after all this time Chris
oh sure yes go what stop you could dodge
bullets idiot it's not afraid your gun
did they forget about you obviously
very bad Netta move right there Jill
come on it's me
Trish step out of it nice move Chris but
now that your partner has arrived
I'll leave you two to catch up chillon
Jill
get yourself together wake up Jill
Valentine sure I'm being pretty useless
right now still resisting it's such an
advanced stage peuta no more time for
games Chris I've got work to do have fun
watching Jill suffer wait what did you
do to her
[Applause]
[Music]
did that alleviate the pain ripping open
her shirt at just restrainer Dodgers we
shot her once though in the in the in
the red thing so you restrain how can
you kill me actually yes wait can we
know there's a red around she's too much
just do it now I don't feel like waiting
yeah I have it right here here here here
okay do it sure I had that damn it
I was close all right OOP all right here
we go
use all right you're welcome girlfriend
okay so you restrain I'll shoot her once
and then we'll get it I've got a handgun
I'll shoot I got into um refiners Jill
what are you doing okay
shoot her once in the chest uh-uh just
happened
got it stun there's Jill answer me it's
me oh she keeps on coming rip it off
this time yeah
I know it takes a couple times
I grabbed it this time come on snap out
of it
she's like monkeying around here all
right
breaking her neck yeah I know just be
careful not to um shooter shooter I
think anymore because I know I know
you're not supposed to do it a lot well
I don't know you got shoot but it
doesn't hurt her when you shoot the
thing when we shot her we shot her once
like in the butt and she like died as
long as you keep shooting the thing is
fine just don't miss her but is her
weakness Mercer who Jill what are you
doing
try shooter sure Oh Circle Circle Circle
you can be Robby shooter yeah
don't miss obviously I'm just afraid
stop this
Jill answer me it's me Chris don't you
recognize man I'll shoot her one more
time do it
do it yeah get it kid and I just done
scared on a shooter in the body it's got
a pretty big hit box it's you don't have
to hit it exactly I mean it has to be
close okay
I like shattering the clavicle last time
I got it well it sounds like it's doing
a good like we're doing it oh no she's
in the monkey stage shoot her in the
face no it's good what what I have gray
hair aren't you
wait it's a boy yeah that's right get it
you're making me uncomfortable
[Music]
doing these in the gutter oh I'm coming
shoot it
[Music]
just tear it off this is the one
[Music]
no it's not time to shoot it all right
stop this Jill answer me
[Music]
stop moving around just shoot there you
go yeah
now get stared off my circle that woman
whoa
get me your bosom hey hey I want to
shoot her so bad right now nothing funny
my heart
Jill your beautiful chest it's been
ruined
she'll never be able to wear v-neck
shirts anymore deep these deep seas I I
can't forgive you your sheva right yes
stay away from my man you thank you it's
an act don't trust her Sheva you listen
I'm gonna be alright
you do need to stop him we can't just
leave you here you have to this is your
only chance
if Wesker succeeds pseudo burrows will
be spread across the globe millions will
die oh yeah I'm all right you need to
stop him Chris you're the only one who
can before it's too late don't you trust
your partner why me you tried to kill me
for like last ten minutes
[Music]
shimshi luck Sam I have to be you guys
know I can hear you right
do you want me leave the room or free
awkward you're our only hope to survive
this have you leave her in the temple
just come up with us and then we can
part ways yeah it seems a bit weird you
stay down here in this temple
over there zombie man booby lady
and the guy made of gold it's time to
put it all right here we go
I'm excited I beat you with SAS Saab we
will play another 10-15 minutes do it
I'm feeling it
I want to be the goddamn game to be
honest with you
me too but I have to hit the bathroom
before we get too far in all right
but like I would straight up I would
stay all night I like want to beat this
game so bad and like not have this ready
almost 6 is gonna be like 25 hours oh my
god where they don't 6 is dumb and
easier to
it was not worth a lot of money
none of these are worth a lot of money
alright this em this one's worth a lot
yeah
alright I'll keep that for now and then
this is my old one right
alright also this okay and I'm just
gonna upgrade a couple things cuz I'm
worth it to Joseph I am gonna treat you
I really like my shotgun
I think that's it sweet oh wait I have
treasures so 10,000 words Oh where'd you
get that what was that oh I just sold
$60,000 worth of treasure I guess um all
right wait oh I guess can't still have
my egg didn't notice I'm really
impressed with you for committing to
something nobody asked of you Oh what
did I just do
soldier no no no you just put in your
without Jesus present organize yeah you
can bring that last rifle you think yeah
the rifles round
mother of God all right
I feel good you ready hmm let's kill
some zombies do de bidis
the Buddha's itty bittys
now you say it 80 dubious happiness
Malraux um y'all play another ten
minutes okay something like that [ __ ]
fish let us let your bladder tell the
tale
oh it is when you're ready using your
ship like this screaming this out too
soon oh really
another plan money never mind I don't
think Oh any more gross it's that beer
and coffee
they're coming out of the woodwork oh
[ __ ] are you okay [ __ ] was that someone
the RPG up top [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh yeah all right if you you get you get
these guys I'll get that guy please I
need you so I got him I got my gun you
did not okay
there was I no no no there was that he
has a leg pad hang on I forgot about
that stupid [ __ ] my bad my fault
damn it they've armed they're all over
the place now it's really dumb it's
give help no I do now
can we use that I really need it yeah
let's do double alright well or do you
not want to do that wait watch out watch
out that guy's got needs I'm just gonna
use this one I heard yeah give it to me
I'll combine them or just give it to me
quick
I'm good Sally all right there's
grenades oh you killed a grenade guy do
you want to save it or you oh I see no
I'm just gonna use a regular one I'll be
fine tulay I use it I made the decision
there we go good because if we get our
red later on then it's better yeah yeah
I want to use both greens there's a
green down here sweet
um I need your Lots I have any right now
that hold on
[Music]
hey these flash grenades I'm not really
using our together those
Hank I would like I'm gonna get rid of
these can you take that green or no yeah
one that you have her no there's one
over here there's also Shogun shells
that I can't take oh [ __ ] dogs can you
[ __ ] shotgun is the name of the game
right now
what yeah I mean you have to like pay
attention where the armor is now hands
on your knees hands on your knees
nice Oh heads up mmm Oh double stomp
ease
check our six our six is clear sweet
let's check out fat guy he's right next
to us and dogs okay
get the [ __ ] down
it's got dead no why just on the ground
is he dead
yes he said [ __ ] why's the body still
there um there's a guy jeez watch out
he's gonna clip I'm trying to you crap
it oh wait you got to shoot that tail
sure yeah she just he'll die is this
guy's face thing we got trip him up and
then shoot that Thanks oh that is
[ __ ] super gross he's alive stop [ __ ]
when we shoot a tail thing and then he's
gonna open up you got on yeah I am
shooting it woohoo
I get ready shotgun I'll shoot the tail
oh I'm not available oh there's a red
there you go there's a red herb uh
there's a red herb over here let me
reload my shotgun I gotta shoot this one
I have a green okay cool you have a cuz
I was gonna say I could hmm doesn't
really solve anything does it
yeah I can bind him oh sweet all right
we don't need yet do you want this
handgun ammo or are you done yeah uh
yeah yeah it's over here you're welcome
let me just reload all my tweet bones
onward and upward forward excelsior um
it's a labyrinth go
I remember this [ __ ] press that button I
pressed it
do I have to stay here and then press it
again so you can get across later I
think the research [ __ ] there's a green
herb over here and I can't take it
really how do you fall those slots cuz I
don't have my channel oh I need a key
card to open it
whoa let's go get well let's go get it
I think I need you to help me push this
okay
so effects team really did a little did
a number on these dogs I could smell
them that's incredible
Wow come on damn it I was trying to kill
her thankee as this is
crap that guy's got your nades on okay
so you just shoot the grenades on that
first Saints brain here
oh [ __ ] you that's sadder behind Jeff
Wade this guy's got grenades let me
shoot him got him
well I got the shield I think I'm story
no no no sure I'm just gonna split she
just tell if I can't
oh no he's it thing he's gonna kill me
hitting him doing some damage
Oh ma'am he's down he's down he's down
oh [ __ ] I can't shoot that part went on
because it was like not facing me I
don't know I mean it still hurts the
shooters tattoo it seems from legend can
you get it tech me or no cuz there's a
guy come come toward me because I've got
shot there's a guy up there throwing
nades and I need to shoot him but I
can't if that guy is running at me so
he's down he's down oh crap I'm working
on it he looks dead and I'm almost out
of ammo for everything yeah I'm done
I hear stressful music alright I'm gonna
use regular greener and then I'll use
the first days berry when I get out I
just need to get this ammo mmm I should
be a button you get rest somewhere for
me Oh
actually I wonder if I could heal you
through the great is worth trying
come come close I'll use a green nerve
to see if it works sweet no um I don't
know uh bug I I honestly don't read that
green switch up there
oh [ __ ] if that's it oh I didn't all
right I'm done well this games done uh
damn just hanging out stay there okay I
need a keycard
all right that's been established oh
it's right here it's on the ground over
to me
what where is it oh you're right it
wasn't like shining like a lot of the
other items
okay key cards been used and then you
got to go up into that crane guy damn
this is boring for me sorry I'm glad I'm
the one with the view though oh are you
coming back down here I don't yeah
that's a grenade I had
ah no console table down here heads out
there dogs coming towards you I must
make a stain near me that would be cool
they did they are idiots what a bunch of
[ __ ] idiot doctor stupid they sure
are
they might just what's happening can't
press that lever at some point
Oh their dog Jimmy to help you or are
you not in danger nope
protected I kill a boat just gonna press
that lever when you get up there yeah
that button one second that's it and
I'll come up there stomp clap stomp
stomp clap pull another dog don't press
the bun yet okay actually so we uh press
whatever
sweet I should be able to that's America
all right I should be able to offer
support I think depending on coming up
Oh some stuff on the way I want to get
on em oh I hear people though yeah I
don't know if you're supposed to come up
here I'm coming back down there's
nothing up here okay yeah there's a lot
of stuff down here actually it's Honda
you got checkpoint I'm just trying to
think what we're supposed to do now
there was um oh there's some machine gun
ammo where I am we found a safe
completely something you don't need I
saw where we need to go kind of just
come back toward me damage got a lot of
gold whoa sweet Oh
gavotte here Oh found him not sure I
don't even know how to explain where I
am oh there you are
kill this dude should be alright
buncha guys all right I'm behind where
the kit yeah off that lighter to the
left okay there's a bunch of guys over
here I don't know why actually oh
there's a green a beer yeah I saw it
those guys here you don't see any oh I
see them
oh no it's the fat ones there's fat guys
here there's two of them
I'm killing these two guys oh yeah
coming
Oh like I [ __ ] me up pretty bad oh
it's him oh you just got knocked that
they were going that way I should jump
across [ __ ] you do you want to do you
want to heal me yeah I jump over here
cuz there's a green herb over here I got
a red and green at first dates Pirellis
the first day it's great alright and
I'll get that green aired once I get to
a she got it all right
I'll go get the green herbs over here I
think we're just where we're supposed to
go I could be wrong
uh yeah we've gotta shoot each other
switches uh hold on a second
maybe you know I mean sound pretty
sexual oh it is
I'll get your switch ready
wait you're kinda give my team a icon
sweet there's a box right next to you
yeah yeah I got em a fool what am i full
I got machine gun ammo all right okay
okay all right wait are we splitting up
again again now we're come back I'm
gonna shot you
there's a box over here Oh dog oh [ __ ]
thank you you're welcome oh you know
dirty yeah nice Bob Oz of red herb over
here with my green herb
a lot of dogs over here um all right I'm
coming they're good
well there's two LS it a lot okay so I
can reload that and then what do I get
this red red somebody with my green yeah
my dogs really dumb though I got locked
out there's a lot I'm fine it's actually
clearing ammo for my red herb over here
sweet red herb come on combine that
there another one [ __ ] there's another
dog over here sit here something we
could be doing instead of fighting them
I mean it doesn't really bother them
down here I guess mine's pretty dumb uh
here let's jump down here this is where
we're going
nothing nothing nothing right let's go
I just keep moving
all right that might have to be the
episode that went swimmingly compared to
yeah that might that's it saving all
right cool next time on Knievel will get
though that green herb in that flashbang
in that first day it's grenade and that
what is that with a blue one pressing
button machine-gun Anna alright she
sorts of stuff down here machine gun
ammo handgun ammo um until he shuts down
the episode I am going to show you as
many spoilers as I can going down the
stairs um
the tanker so big next week it's III we
should have an episode up
I can't 100% promise but we're gonna try
very hard to record like if you're
watching this we're probably gonna be
recording a few hours after you watch it
if you watch when we publish but other
than that we will try to get as many
we'll finish five probably in the next
episode the thing about like up
publishing the episodes we're not going
to do it like on e3 right because like
nobody gives a [ __ ] so like we have to
kind of do it you know okay when I'm
turning gameplay off do you guys Chris
is spoiling [ __ ] we'll see everybody
next weekend resonate can evil president
Knievel forever to be so bad